bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va
reparler de spinoza ce qui nous a on en
avait parlé dans une précédente vidéo et
j'avais choisi de vous introduire à sa
pensée par la question du libre arbitre
et du déterminisme c'est généralement le
thème le plus classique lorsqu'on veut
aborder la philosophie de spinoza
reparler de sa conception du libre
arbitre et c'est généralement aussi la
porte d'entrée la plus accessible mais
dans cette précédente vidéo nous
n'avions fait qu'effleurer la doctrine
de spinoza et sa vision du monde
ce qui justifie que je fasse aujourd'hui
une deuxième vidéo pour essayer de
préciser de développer d'approfondir
certaines choses que nous avons
seulement aborder de manière
superficielle et qui mérite aujourd'hui
d'être sérieusement approfondie alors
pour rappel spinoza et est un philosophe
juif néerlandais d'origine portugaise du
xviie siècle
il est intéressant de noter que ses
positions en matière de religion lui ont
valu l'excommunication en 1656 et cette
excommunication qu'a subie spinoza vient
du fait que sa conception de dieu
s'écarter un peu trop et c'est un
euphémisme de la conception judaïque et
même de la conception monothéistes tout
court à tel point d'ailleurs que spinoza
renoncé à publier les tics de son vivant
et que le deuxième ouvrage dans lequel
il parle de la question de dieu
le traité théologico-politique a été
publié sous un faux nom
spinoza était conscient que exposé une
conception de dieu qui s'écarte un petit
peu trop de la conception classique
aurait pu lui porter un grave préjudice
et donc par prudence il a préféré ne pas
faire connaître ses vues de manière
explicite de son vivant
la question est évidemment qu'on se pose
ici c'est que rejette spinoza dans la
conception classique de dieu donc on va
commencer dans cette vidéo par parler
des désaccords que spinoza à avec la
conception classique de dieu la première
chose que spinoza roja dans la
conception classique de dieu c'est
l'idée que dieu serait un être doté
d'une volonté qui aurait un projet et
dont nous autres êtres humains serions
quelque sorte le résultat c'est l'idée
qu' on pourrait prêter à dieu
des propriétés qui sont également les
propriétés de l'être humain et qu'est ce
que j'entends par propriétés bien je
parle principalement des sentiments que
l'on attribue à dieu de ses pensées
voire de ses désirs et qu'on retrouve
dans de nombreuses descriptions qui sont
faites dans la bible des réactions de
dieu au comportement des hommes dans
l'ancien testament on nous présente un
dieu vengeur un dieu colérique un dieu
impitoyable or ce sont là des sentiments
qui selon spinoza sont le propre de
l'être humain mais ne peuvent pas être
attribué à un être parfait et infini
tels que dieu en réalité ce que dénonce
spinoza c'est la conception
anthropomorphique de dieu c'est la
vision de dieu qui consiste à lui prêter
des propriétés humaine c'est-à-dire des
propriétés d'être finie et un parfait en
quelque sorte
spinoza reproche aux hommes d'avoir créé
un dieu à leur image et vous savez que
cette phrase très connu qui dit que dieu
a créé l'homme à son image
une phrase qui a donné lieu à de très
nombreuses interprétations bien c'est
comme si spinoza ici retournez cette
phrase contre l'homme et lui reprochait
d'avoir une vision pour le moins limité
de la nature de dieu
donc retenons bien ici que le premier
désaccord que l'on peut identifier chez
spinoza vis-à-vis du monothéisme
vis-à-vis de la conception classique de
dieu c'est cet anthropomorphisme c'est
cette projection sur dieu des propriétés
humaine qui selon spinoza n'est pas du
tout adapté à la nature véritable de
dieu alors pourquoi est ce que cette
projection sur dieu des propriétés
humaine postel problème bien le pose
problème parce que comme je les dis
rapidement dieu est un être parfait et
infini et ça ça fait partie de la
définition même du concept dieu
entendons nous bien
on n'est pas ici en train de parler de
l'existence ou de l'inexistence de dieu
on est en train de parler de sa
définition on est en train de parler de
ce qui fait que dieu est dieu dieu est
un être parfait et infini et de ce fait
ne peut pas être pourvu des
caractéristiques des êtres imparfaits
est finie que nous sommes et ça on peut
le démontrer à ses fascinants on va
reprendre l'exemple du désir selon
spinoza la création du monde n'est pas
le fruit d'une volonté de dieu n'est pas
le fruit d'un désir divin par scan être
parfait ne peut pas avoir de désir
rappelez vous on l'avait déjà dit dans
d'autres vidéos le désirent c'est le
témoignage du manque le désir c'est la
marque de l'absence vous souvenez du
mythe des androgynes chez platon dans le
banquet de platon diotime nous explique
que l'origine du désir c'est la
séparation de l'humain originel en 2
être distincts hommes et femmes et que
le désir consiste justement à rejoindre
sa partie manquante
quand vous désirez quelque chose quoi
que ce soit vous désirez vous unir à
cette chose vous désirez ne faire plus
qu'un avec cette chose que ce soit par
union physiques charnelles ce soit par
l'union intellectuelle ou spirituelle
lorsque vous avez par exemple de la
curiosité dans un domaine l'acte de
connaissances qui va satisfaire votre
curiosité est un acte par lequel vous ne
fait plus qu'un avec l'objet de votre
curiosité
vous êtes approprié l'objet de votre
curiosité sous la forme d'une
connaissance
donc on peut bien ici parler d'union
intellectuelle de la même façon
avoir une relation sexuelle avec une
personne que vous désirez c'est une
manière de ne faire plus qu'un avec elle
donc le désir est bien la marque d'une
volonté de réunification et on ne peut
réunifiée que ce qui a été séparée mais
chez dieu rien et c'est paraît il n'ya
pas d'extériorité à dieu qui
justifierait que dieu est un désir
il n'y a rien qui puisse faire défaut à
dieu il n'y a rien qui puisse lui
manquer considérer que dieu aurait une
volonté ou un désir ses présupposés que
dieu n'est pas parfait puisque alors il
lui manque quelque chose
l'idée que dieu a créé le monde parce
qu'il en avait la volonté ses
présupposés que dieu manquer de quelque
chose ces présupposés que dieu n'est pas
parfait donc là selon spinoza
on a un problème quasiment d'ordre
logique on peut pas définir dieu par sa
perfection tout en reconnaissant
parallèlement qu'il avait besoin de
créer le monde pour être ce qu'il est je
vais prendre un autre exemple pour
illustrer cette contradiction logique
qui identifie spinoza c'est l'idée que
dieu serait pourvue de sentiments parler
d'un dieu vengeur parler d'un dieu
colérique parler d'un dieu qui
finalement ne sait pas maîtriser ses
émotions importe linosa ça pose problème
parce que ça voudrait dire que dieu ne
vaut pas mieux que nous
ça voudrait dire que dieu est soumis aux
mêmes imperfections au même contingent
ce que l'être humain et ça pour spinoza
ça n'a aucun sens ça témoigne seulement
d'une vision réductrice de dieu d'une
vision un petit peu limité vision
limitée qui est tout à fait justifiable
par le simple fait que forcément
lorsqu'on essaye de penser quelque chose
on va le penser à partir de ce que nous
sommes
ça c'est normal mais le fait de
prétendre que ce que nous projetons sur
dieu soit la vérité ça pour spinoza
c'est un problème
et c'est évidemment un problème qui est
très difficile à aborder pour spinoza
parce qu'en s'attaquant à cette
conception réductrice de dieu spinoza a
bien conscience que ça ne va pas plaire
au pouvoir religieux le pouvoir
religieux a besoin que les fidèles
croient dans un dieu vengeur ou
colériques un dieu qui ne va pas hésiter
à les punir si jamais il se comporte mal
un dieu qui sera le maître du jugement
dernier et qui fait peser sur l'homme
la promesse du paradis où la menace de
l'enfer
si dieu tout à coup n'a plus de
sentiments la plus d'émotions n'a plus
de désir bien comment faire que les
fidèles se comporte comme on voudrait
qu'ils se comportent
il ne s'agit pas dire que la religion se
réduisent seulement un instrument de
domination mais il s'agit de comprendre
que dans une dialectique entre religion
et politique le pouvoir religieux a
intérêt à ce que nous et plusieurs cette
conception anthropomorphique de dieu si
demain on se met à dire que quoi qu'on
fasse quelles que soient nos fautes
quelles que soient nos crimes quelles
que soient nos péchés dieu n'en sera pas
affectée puisque de toute façon il n'a
pas de sentiments il n'a pas de projets
il n'a pas de valeur
ça revient à dire faites ce que vous
voulez c'est comme si dieu disait faites
ce que vous voulez pour moi ça change
rien
donc ça c'est pas possible du point de
vue du pouvoir religieux c'est pas
possible de laisser passer ça c'est pas
possible de véhicules et une telle
conception qui évidemment porte en elle
le risque de l'anarchie donc pour
spinoza
dieu n'a ni affecte ni désir ni projets
ni volonté il est
on pourrait dire ils se contentent
d'être ils se contentent d'être
autrement dit il n'attend rien d'eux
nous dieu n'attend rien de nous il
n'attend rien non parce que attendre
c'est vouloir
et qu'est ce qu'on veut on veut ce qu'on
n'a pas on veut ce qui nous manque on
veut ce de quoi nous dépendons or pour
spinoza dieu ne dépend de rien il
n'attend rien des hommes et toute
proposition qui consisterait à dire que
les hommes devraient se comporter de
telle ou telle façon
selon spinoza salle à d'autres fonctions
que de maintenir la domination sur les
esprits reprendre l'image freudienne
dieu n'est pas notre père nous n'avons
pas besoin de le craindre
nous n'avons pas besoin de lui vouer un
culte et finalement la conception
classique de dieu selon spinoza traduit
davantage ce qu'est la nature humaine
que la nature de dieu nous projetons sur
dieu ce que nous voulons pour nous mêmes
qu'est ce que nous voulons nous voulons
que les autres nous respecte que les
autres se soumettent à notre volonté
nous voulons de la reconnaissance ou
voulons du dévouement et toutes ses
attentes et tous ses désirs et toutes
ses volontés que nous investissons dans
dieu en réalité nous les investissons
dans les autres êtres humains
je vais passer directement au deuxième
des accords que spinoza formule
vis-à-vis de la conception classique de
dieu dans la conception classique
dieu est considéré comme un être
extérieur au monde comme un être séparée
de la nature
j'emploierai ici le mot nature comme un
synonyme de réalité matérielle
dieu n'est pas séparée du monde
autrement dit dieu n'est pas un être
transcendant au monde n'est pas un être
au dessus du monde et ça va même plus
loin puisque pour spinoza dieu n'est pas
à proprement parler
le créateur du monde être le créateur du
monde ça présupposerait que dieu est
extérieur au monde et qu'il est aussi
antérieure au monde
autrement dit que dieu précéderait la
création ça paraît assez logique
effectivement dans la plupart des textes
religieux c'est ce qu'on nous dit on dit
que l'éternel a créé le monde et pour
qu'il le crès il fallait bien que dieu
soit avant le monde
dieu n'a pas pu créer quelque chose
avant lui même pour ainsi dire c'est à
dire que dans la conception religieuse
traditionnelle le monde a un début
temporel qui correspond à l'acte
volontaire de dieu l'acte volontaire de
création du monde
donc là encore une fois on a un schéma
anthropomorphique c'est à dire l'idée
qu'il ya d'abord une volonté un projet
et ensuite une création qui découle de
cette volonté
ce qu'on appellerait en termes
philosophiques une actualisation de la
volonté actualisé ça signifie rendre
réel rendre effectif vous avez un projet
qui peut être par exemple de passer une
semaine de vacances en espagne d'abord
vous avez l'idée vous avez l'intention
le projet est ensuite va vous prenez vos
billets vous prenez votre avion et vous
allez passer les vacances conformément à
votre projet donc il ya bien ici l'idée
d'une succession dans le temps
c'est à dire d'une antériorité du projet
par rapport à la mise en oeuvre du
projet eh bien ça encore pour spinoza
ça ne tient pas debout ça ne tient pas
debout parce que ça ne prend pas en
compte le fait que dieu et le monde dieu
et la nature c'est la même chose
qu'est ce que ça veut dire dieu et le
monde c'est la même chose ça veut dire
que tout ce qui existe dans le monde est
un reflet est une expression une
manifestation de dieu
ce micro qui est posé en face de moi cet
arbre qui se trouve derrière ma fenêtre
vous même qui m'écoutent et nous sommes
tous des expressions de dieu nous sommes
tous des reflets des témoignages des
manifestations de dieu donc pour spinoza
mme dieu c'est le monde et le monde
c'est dieu alors il ya cette citation
extrêmement connue par les lecteurs de
spinoza qui consiste à dire dieu ou la
nature des housses si wayne à tour à
dieu ou la nature
ça signifie dieu égale la nature dieu
s'identifie coïncide avec la nature
dieu est la nature c'est la même chose
et donc là on va s'arrêter sur ce que
signifie cette expression dieu c'est à
dire la nature qu'est ce que ça veut
dire se c'est à dire qu'est ce que ça
implique
ou est-ce que spinoza veut nous emmener
en lisant ça
comment faut-il le comprendre pour le
comprendre il faut revenir sur une idée
vraiment maîtresse de la doctrine de
spinoza qui est la doctrine de la
substance et des attributs
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire la
substance c'est le nom que donne spinoza
à dieu est la substance ce classiquement
en philosophie en métaphysique
on pourrait dire que c'est l'essence de
toute chose
les sens elle apostrophe autrement dit
le principe de tout ce qui est c'est ça
la substance le principe de tout ce qui
est étymologiquement substance soupe
stante ya c'est ce qui se tient en
dessous donc on n'est pas du tout dans
une définition matérialiste de la
substance c'est pas du tout la substance
chimique par exemple c'est pas ça c'est
ce qui se tient derrière la réalité
matérielle de toute chose
et donc maintenant qu'on a vu ce qu
était la substance
on va voir ce que sont les attributs à
la tribu c'est une propriété de la
substance
si vous préférez un attribut c'est une
manière particulière de considérer la
substance un attribut c'est un point de
vue sur la substance
donc pour l'expliquer je vais recourir à
une analogie qui comme toute analogie
forcément sera imparfaite mais c'est
simplement pour vous donner une image
prenons une fleur on va imaginer une
rose une rose rouge donc avec sa tige
avec ses épines maintenant imaginez que
cette rose on la présente à votre regard
et on vous demande de la décrire qu'est
ce que vous allez dire vous allez dire
par exemple c'est une rose rouge
vous allez là caractérisé par son aspect
visuel concurrence par sa couleur
bon mais ça on est bien d'accord que
c'est une caractéristique parmi d'autres
de la rose sa couleur ne suffit pas à la
définir on est bien d'accord
maintenant imaginons qu'on prenne une
deuxième personne qu'on lui demande de
fermer les yeux et qu'on lui fasse
touché la rose alors référence
on lui fera toucher la tige avec les
épines sinon c'est pas drôle mais on lui
fera aussi touché les pétales bien sûr
nous demandera la personne de
reconnaître ce qu'on lui fait toucher
c'est la personne déjà une rose en main
elle sera la reconnaître par rapport à
ses caractéristiques tactile par rapport
à sa texture donc grâce au sens du
toucher les caractéristiques que cette
personne va identifier
c'est à dire l'aspect piquant de la tige
l'aspect lisse et doux des pétales ça
aussi ça fait partie des
caractéristiques de la rose
on ne peut pas ôter ses propriétés de ce
qu'est la rose
si vous préférez une rose n'est pas
simplement un objet visuel c'est aussi
un objet tactile c'est quelque chose que
l'on peut toucher
donc on se retrouve ici avec deux
manières différentes de caractériser la
même chose c'est-à-dire la rose et bien
entendu on peut également faire ça pour
l'odorat
on va faire sentir le parfum de la rose
et ce parfum sera également l'une des
propriétés de la rose très bien
qu'est-ce qu'on va conclure de tout ça
bien on va conclure que son prend un
objet quelconque
il ya plusieurs manières de caractériser
cet objet il ya plusieurs manières de se
rapporter à lui en l'occurrence ça va
dépendre du sens que l'on choisit il
canal sensorielle que l'on choisit si on
choisit le canal visuel
va caractériser la rose par sa couleur
éventuellement par sa forme
si on choisit le canal du toucher on va
caractériser la rose par sa texture la
texture de sa tige de ses pétales et si
on choisit le canal de l'odorat on va
caractériser la rose par son parfum
on est bien d'accord que chacun de ces
canaux sensorielle se rapporte à la même
chose à la rose donc si quelqu'un nous
disait par exemple que une rose c'est
quelque chose qui sent bon
ou que c'est quelque chose de rouge mais
qui occulterait les autres
caractéristiques sensible de la rose et
on dirait que cette personne elle a un
point de vue partielle de ce qu'est une
rose elle ne l'envisagerait que sous
certains aspects et bien c'est ça un
attribut chez spinoza un attribut c'est
une manière de considérer quelque chose
et quand je parle de manière de
considérer quelque chose je parle d'un
angle de vue d'une dimension qui certes
ne résume pas ce qu'est l'objet mais qui
pourtant fait partie de ses
caractéristiques essentielles
voilà ce qu'est un attribut chez spinoza
un attribut c'est une manière de se
rapporter à un objet c'est une manière
de l'envisager c'est un point de vue sur
lui qui n'exclut pas d'autres attributs
mais qui fait que selon la tribu sous
lequel on va considérer cet objet on
n'aura pas à faire exactement à la même
chose vous savez c'est comme cette fable
des six aveugle et de l'éléphant chacun
des aveugles va toucher une partie
différent du corps de l'éléphant et va
croire qu'il a à faire à quelque chose
de radicalement différent des autres
le premier aveugle va toucher le flanc
d'éléphant et penser qu'il s'agit d'un
mur le deuxième va toucher une défense
et pensent qu'il s'agit d'une lance le
troisième va toucher à la tromper penser
qu'il s'agit d'un serpent bref dans tous
les cas chacun des points de vue se
défend
chacun de ces points de vue est vrai de
son propre point de vue mais le fait est
que chacune des parties du corps de
l'éléphant ne permet pas de comprendre
ce qu'est un éléphant est bien chez
spinoza remet un attribut c'est l'une
des propriétés l'une des
caractéristiques de la substance infinie
que spinoza rappel
dieu c'est la substance c'est cette
totalité parfaite et infini et les
attributs ce sont les rapports les
aspects les dimensions sous lesquels on
peut envisager la substance alors ce qui
est intéressant au sujet des attributs
c'est que spinoza nous dit que la
substance possède une infinité
d'attribuer une infinité évidemment
c'est quelque chose qu'on ne peut pas se
représenter
justement parce que nous sommes des
êtres fini nous sommes très très très
loin de pouvoir concevoir tous les
attributs de la substance
tous les attributs de dieu si noah nous
dit que nous autres êtres humains nous
ne sommes capables de reconnaître que
deux attributs et ces deux attributs ce
sont les tendu
c'est à dire la matière et la pensée
l'étendue et la pensée sont les deux
seuls attributs de la substance que
l'être humain est capable de concevoir
si vous préférez je veux dire la manière
la plus simple possible
tout ce que vous allez envisagée dans le
monde
vous allez soit l'envisager du point de
vue physique
du point de vue matériel donc du point
de vu de l'étendue soit du point de vue
de la pensée du point de vue spirituel
du point de vue intellectuel
donc du point de vue immatériel et vous
pouvez essayer de démentir spinoza si
vous essayez d'envisager un autre
attribut que l'étendue où la pensée
c'est à dire que la matière ou l'esprit
espinosa vous répondra que vous n'y
arriverez pas vous n'y arriverez pas
parce que nous sommes pour ainsi dire
constitué ainsi nous sommes dotés d'un
équipement cognitif l'équipement qui
nous permet de de connaître le monde
d'en avoir conscience et qui passe par
ces deux canaux la matière et l'esprit
et d'ailleurs ça rejoint la position du
à liste de descartes
sauf que pour des cartes il y avait bien
deux substances indépendante dont l'une
était de nature matérielle et l'autre de
nature spirituelle
d'où la distinction chez descartes entre
le corps et l'esprit
et cette conception qui l'avait de l'âme
qui échappait aux déterminismes matériel
pour spinoza au contraire il n'y a pas
de séparation il y à une cohabitation
des différents attributs au sein de la
substance de la même façon qu'il ya
cohabitation des propriétés propriétés
sensorielles au sein de la rose vous
n'allez pas dire qu'il est faux de dire
que la rose et rouge sous prétexte que
ses pétales sont doux ça n'aurait aucun
sens
ça n'aurait aucun sens comme ça n'aurait
aucun sens de dire que quelqu'un ne
porte pas de lunettes sous prétexte
qu'il porte un short et bien qu'on est
sur des choses qui n'ont pas de sens
d'un point de vue logique on peut très
bien la fois porter des lunettes et
portait un short on peut à la fois être
de couleur rouge comme une rose peut
parfaitement être de couleur rouge et en
même temps avoir des pétales qu'ils
soient d'où donc l'idée des attributs
chez spinoza ben c'est tout simplement
l'idée que parmi les caractéristiques de
la substance
nous n'avons accès qu'à deux d'entre
elles est que ces deux attributs ces
deux dimensions de la substance ne sont
pas en conflit l'une avec l'autre
les attributs de dieu ne sont pas en
conflit les uns avec les autres
ils sont bretons dire complémentaires
ils cohabitent
ils ne sont pas exclusifs c'est à dire
que la reconnaissance de l'un n'implique
pas le rejet de l'autre et ils sont en
nombre infini ce qui ne veut pas dire
que nous soyons capables de tous les
connaître puisque en tant qu'être humain
c'est-à-dire en tant qu être limité en
tant qu'être qui sommes nous mêmes
composés de deux attributs la matière et
l'esprit
nous ne sommes capables de connaître que
ces deux attributs alors souvent on pose
la question oui même ça comment est-ce
que spinoza le sait comment est ce qu il
sait que dieu c'est à dire la nature
possède une infinité d'attributs et que
nous serons capables que d'en connaître
que deux doigts est ce qu'il ne sort ça
mais il le sort d'abord de la définition
qui donne de dieu comme dan être parfait
et infini donc il est logique qu'un être
infinie soit dotée d'une infinité de la
tribu jusque là y'a pas de problème
et pourquoi ne sommes nous capables d'en
connaître que deux mais bien parce que
nous sommes ainsi structurée nous sommes
ainsi constitué nous sommes ce que
spinoza appelle des composés de matières
et d'esprit est d'ailleurs tout ce qui
existe dans le monde est un composé de
matières et d'esprit
ces composés de matières et d'esprit
c'est ce que spinoza appelle les modes
les modes de la substance les modes de
la substance qui sont décomposées
d'attributs de la substance alors pour
que ça vous paraissent un peu plus clair
parce que j'ai bien conscience que ce
que je suis en train de vous raconter
vous paraîtra soit très abstrait soit
très bizarre je vous ai fait un petit
schéma 1 parce que un petit dessin vaut
parfois mieux qu'un long discours
voilà et aussi parce que je suis un
grand artiste et sur ce chemin
j'essaie de représenter ce dont je vous
parle depuis tout à l'heure c'est à dire
que le cercle grands cercles représente
la substance j'ai choisi le cercle bien
que ce soit une représentation
imparfaite
le cercle étant généralement la figure
géométrique qui sert un représenter la
totalité mais vous aurez remarqué que
j'ai fait une sorte doré hall autour de
ce cercle et je vous expliquerai
pourquoi tout à l'heure ce qui fait que
notre substance ressemble plus ou moins
un soleil à l'intérieur de ce cercle
j'ai tracé quelques rayons il faut
imaginer qu'il y ait une infinité de
rayon chaque rayon représentant un
attribut alors je ne l'ait pas fait plus
parce que si j'avais voulu faire une
infinité de rayon eh bien mon cercle
serait devenu un disque et on aurait
plus vue là la distinction la différence
entre chaque rayon c'est à dire entre
chaque attribue donc j'ai voulu laisser
de l'espace entre les différents rayons
et donc j'ai mentionné les deux rayons
qui correspondent à nos deux attributs
la tribu de la pensée la tribu de la
matière et sur chacun de ses rayons donc
de ses attributs j'ai fait des segments
des segments qui sont comme des
passerelles comme des ponts entre les
attributs pour indiquer cette
interaction entre les attributs qui fait
que tout ce qui existe dans le monde est
un composé de plusieurs attributs
et comme on sait que chez spinoza
l'ordre et la connexion des choses sont
les mêmes que l'ordre et la connexion
des idées et bien j'ai fait des
passerelles j'ai fait des segments
parallèle entre eux pour bien montrer
qu'à un certain niveau sur la tribu de
la matière sur la tribu de l'étendue va
correspondre à niveau sur la tribu de la
pensée
donc ces petits segments qui font
rejoindre les deux attributs c'est ce
que spinoza appelle les modes
donc nous sommes tous des modes des
modes de dieu des modes de la substance
des composés de matières et d'esprit qui
sont eux-mêmes deux attributs parmi une
infinité d'autres de la substance que
dieu alors je reviens maintenant sur
cette auréole que j'ai tracée autour de
mon cercle et par laquelle j'ai voulu
signifier l'idée d'un dynamisme
l'idée d'une production parce que c'est
très important de comprendre que la
substance chez spinoza c'est à dire dieu
n'est pas quelque chose de fixe n'est
pas quelque chose de figé immobile comme
on décrit généralement dieu dans les
anciens systèmes métaphysique par
exemple chez platon ou chez aristote
donc spinoza par le bas explicitement de
ce caractère dynamique de la substance
divine c'est moi qui en parle parce que
ça va nous permettre de comprendre une
distinction fondamentale que festino à
propos de dieu
donc on a dit que dieu et la nature
c'était la même chose considéré sous un
rapport différent
autrement dit considérer sous un
attribut différent et ça ça permet
d'éclairer la distinction que fit
spinoza entre la nature nature hante et
la nature nature et alors c'est assez
étrange à l'oreille d'entendre une forme
verbaliser du mot nature ça semble
indiquer un processus ça semble indiquer
un travail de production la nature
nature entre c'est la nature qui est
pour ainsi dire emprunt de nature et et
la nature nature et c'est le résultat de
ce travail de la nature
donc qu'est-ce que ça veut dire et ça
veut dire que selon le mode sous lequel
on va la considérer la nature est soit
un acte de production un acte de
création entre guillemets et ça ça
rejoint ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
sur la création du monde
donc la nature nature hantz est la
nature en tant qu elle se déploie en
tant quel sens gendre elle-même tandis
que la nature nature et c'est la nature
du point de vue du résultat fini de ce
travail
si vous préférez le monde que nous
habitons c'est à la fois un monde qui
est toujours en train de se créer
et c'est aussi le monde qui est capable
de nous accueillir en tant que création
c'est quelque chose qu'on peut
facilement représenté par une métaphore
par exemple la métaphore de l'enfant
donc qui a des parents qui sont ses
géniteurs et une fois que l'enfant sera
adulte il pourra lui-même devenir un
géniteur c'est à dire il pourra lui-même
donné la vie nous sommes les enfants de
ceux qui nous ont précédés et les
parents d'une ce qu'ils vont nous
presser des quelque chose d'assez facile
à comprendre je pense donc l'enfance et
la nature nature et c'est le résultat
d'un engendrement la nature nature entre
c'est l'enfant qui lorsqu'il est devenu
adulte va à son tour donné naissance à
d'autres enfants dont on voit ici que
quand on dit dieu ou la nature sous
entendant par là une équivalence voir
une identité entre dieu et la nature des
recettes distinction entre nature nature
en thé nature nature et permet
d'éclairer cette identité permet de
mieux comprendre cette idée
d'équivalence entre dieu et la nature
dieu ce serait le principe nature en de
la nature tandis que la nature telle
qu'on entend habituellement c'est à dire
le monde physique le monde matériel
c'est le résultat de cette engendrement
et encore une fois je le répète il ne
s'agit pas ici d'un acte de création
volontaire de la nature par dieu parce
que ce serait attribuée à dieu une
volonté une intention qui ne possèdent
pas c'est tout ça
le mans le fruit de la puissance de dieu
qui se manifeste à travers le monde
chez spinoza tout ce qui est correspond
à tout ce qui peut être c'est ça la
théorie de la puissance chez spinoza
c'est pour ça que c'est spinoza ya pas
de longues discussions sur la différence
entre ce que l'on peut faire et ce que
l'on fait vraiment parce qu'ils n'osent
à ce que l'on peut faire c'est ce que
l'on fait et ce qu'on ne fait pas c'est
qu'on n'a pas pu le faire il n'y a pas
de conditionnel chez spinoza ont fait ou
on fait pas vous savez il ya beaucoup de
personnes qui sont spécialistes dans le
fait de dire je les ai pas fait mais
j'aurais pu le faire mais cette phrase
n'a strictement aucun sens dans une
situation la chose n'a pas été fait
donc si on voulait vraiment simplifié
pour que ce soit plus facile à
comprendre
on pourrait dire qu'il existe dieu dans
son principe d'engendrement ce que les
religions métaphorise comme étant dieu
le créateur dieu le père et on à dieu
dans sa manifestation matériels et
physiques qui est la nature et dont nous
faisons partie
voilà pourquoi d'un certain point de vue
nous sommes dieu puisque nous sommes la
manifestation de la substance divine
d'ailleurs je fais une petite parenthèse
on entend souvent dire que spinoza fut
l'un des premiers philosophe athée à thé
parce que sa conception de dieu serait
une conception purement matérialiste qui
consisterait à dire dieu c'est la nature
et certaines personnes qui n'ont pas
réellement lu spinoza ou n'ont pas bien
compris ce qu'il est c'est à dire nous
disent qu en fait faut pas chercher plus
loin
spinoza a mis le mot dieu sur la nature
pour pas avoir d'ennuis bon on a vu tout
à l'heure que c'était impossible dans ce
cas là il aurait publié son oeuvre de
son vivant ce qu'il n'a pas fait il
savait très bien que ne suffisait pas de
dire dieu ou la nature pour éviter les
problèmes
donc non c'est pas que spinoza appelle
la nature dieu c'est pas ça c'est qui
distingue au sein de la même substance
deux modes d'être qui sont premièrement
le principe d'engendrement la nature
nature hante
deuxièmement le résultat de
l'engendrement la nature naturel
mais pour spinoza il n'y a pas de
distinction au sens où il n'y a pas de
séparation entre les deux ordres de la
même façon que vous pouvez être à la
fois l'enfant de vos parents et le
parent de vos enfants a pas de
contradiction
il n'y a pas d'incompatibilité entre ces
deux statues voyez vous êtes à la fois
nature nature et en tant qu'enfant de
vos parents et nature nature ans en tant
que parents de nos enfants ça ne
s'excluent pas hier chez spinoza dieu et
la nature c'est la même chose
considérée sous deux aspects différents
n'oublions pas que spinoza défend une
vision moniste du monde c'est à dire une
vision dans laquelle la séparation entre
le corps et l'esprit n'est qu'une
séparation artificielle qui provient de
ce besoin qu'a l'être humain de
dissocier les choses pour pouvoir les
comprendre leur était pour spinoza a pas
de distinction entre la matière et
l'esprit
ce sont les deux rayons du même cercle
il ya donc une différence de points de
vue entre les deux
donc je disais que on peut pas réduire
spinoza à un athée à quelqu'un qui prône
une vision à thé du monde du simple fait
qu'il aurait mis en correspondance dieu
et la nature ce que veut dire spinoza
c'est que nous avons tort de chercher
dieu en dehors du monde puisque dieu se
trouve dans tout ce qui est non pas sous
la forme d'un principe d'engendrement
mais sous la forme du résultat de cette
engendrement nous sommes des expressions
de dieu au sens où nous sommes le
résultat de l'engendrement de la
substance
nous sommes des manifestations de dieu
au sens où nous sommes des modes
d'expression de la substance divine donc
si j'insiste là dessus c'est parce que
je ne voudrais pas laisser croire que la
vision qu'on a habituellement de spinoza
comme d'un auteur matérialiste serait
une vision qui fait l'unanimité au sein
des commentateurs de spinoza non spinoza
n'est pas considéré par tous les
commentateurs comme un philosophe
matérialiste
parce que tout simplement il n'est pas
plus matérialiste que spiritualiste
puisque justement il ne cesse de nous
dire que la matière et l'esprit c'est
exactement la même chose considéré sous
deux points de vue différents
donc évidemment si vous voulez défendre
une vision matérialiste de la
philosophie de spinoza
il vous suffit d'enlever toute la moitié
qui ne vous plaît pas tout la moitié qui
concerne donc l'esprit et de dire vous
voyez spinoza est un matérialiste mais
si vous avez envie de faire de spinoza
un auteur spiritualiste vous pouvez le
faire tout aussi bien à ce moment-là il
vous suffit d'enlever toute la partie où
il parle de la nature au sens matériel
donc non on ne peut pas ramener dans le
giron ni du matérialisme ni du
spiritualisme un auteur qui lui-même ne
cesse de répéter que les deux attributs
sont indissociables les deux attributs
fonctionnent ensemble donc cette
expression de spinoza dieu ou la nature
il faut entendre le ou comme un
changement d'attribution lequel on va
considérer dieu comme un changement de
point de vue sur la substance c'est pas
un ou qui veut dire que dieu et la
nature c'est exactement la même chose
c'est un coût qui signifie que selon le
point de vue dans lequel on se place
on va soit considéré la substance du
point de vue de ce qu'elle engendre du
point de vue de la nature nature hante
ou bien là considéré du point de vue du
produit de cette engendrement c'est à
dire de la nature nature est alors pour
terminer cette vidéo j'aimerais aborder
une dernière notion qui vous allez voir
est en lien avec la précédente vidéo sur
spinoza
il s'agit de la notion de liberté et de
la liberté chez dieu vous rappeler qu'on
a dit que chez spinoza tout est
déterminé au sens où tout obéit à la loi
implacable de la causalité et la
causalité
elle touche invariablement les objets
physiques mais aussi les objets
intellectuelle les objets spirituel
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
tout simplement que la chaîne de
causalité
elle affecte aussi bien les corps
physique que les idées que les pensées
donc l'enchaînement de vos idées
l'enchaînement de vos pensées obéit à la
même loi de la causalité que les corps
physique et c'est ce qui faisait dire à
spinoza que le libre arbitre était
d'abord une illusion
on sait pas ce qu'on est allé au bout la
lecture de l'éthique qu'on a donc lu le
livre 5 qu'une liberté relative est
accessible à l'homme
à partir du moment où l'homme prend
conscience de la nature et de l'origine
de ces
action c'est-à-dire lorsqu'il comprend
de quelle manière il est affecté par le
monde
c'est à ce moment là que l'homme peut se
dégager de la chaîne déterministe en la
comprenant c'est à dire en agissant plus
sous l'impulsion de forces extérieures
mais en agissant sous l'impulsion de sa
propre nature et ça ça va me permettre
d'introduire la notion de liberté chez
dieu kiné mais alors absolument pas la
liberté dont nous parlons habituellement
dans son sens courant la liberté de dieu
n'a strictement rien à voir avec ce que
nous avons coutume d'appeler la liberté
à tel point que spinoza utilise même eu
une expression qui paraît contradictoire
dans les termes puisque spinoza parle de
libre nécessité alors que dit il
exactement
il nous dit que la liberté c'est le fait
d'agir en étant déterminé que par soi
même
autrement dit que la liberté n'est pas
le fait de ne pas être déterminée la
liberté n'est pas l'indétermination la
liberté c'est le pouvoir de
s'autodéterminer dans les tic spinoza
nous explique à quel point nous sommes
déterminés et nous ne sommes pas
déterminé la plupart du temps par nous
mêmes nous sommes la plupart du temps
déterminé par des facteurs externes par
notre environnement par notre milieu par
notre éducation tout ce que vous voulez
en revanche pour spinoza il est possible
de passer à l'autodétermination par la
compréhension des causes qui nous
détermine et du coup que veut dire être
libre chez spinoza ça signifie suivre sa
nature et ça c'est très important de le
comprendre parce que sa part une idée
assez paradoxal on n'est pas habitué à
entendre que la liberté
ce serait le fait de suivre sa nature ça
nous fait même tout de suite pensé au
comportement instinctif des animaux un
lyon qui va chasser pour survivre
d'une certaine manière il va suivre
l'impulsion de sa propre nature mais le
fait est que l'être humain possède un
esprit possède une conscience qui fait
que suivre sa nature ça ne veut pas
forcément dire suivre son instinct pour
l'être humain suivent sa nature ce n'est
pas suivre son instinct nos qu'il y
aurait toute une réflexion à mener sur
ce que signifie agir conformément à sa
nature agir sous l'impulsion de sa
nature juste
après suppose que nous aurions tous une
nature une essence plus ou moins
impersonnel plus ou moins universel mais
en tout cas l'idée c'est que la liberté
ce ne serait pas une émancipation
vis-à-vis de notre nature
mais au contraire la conformité la
correspondance à notre nature
les as une idée qu'il faut bien
comprendre si on ne veut pas faire dire
à spinoza le contraire de ce qu'il dit
parce que très souvent on veut citer
spinoza pour dire que le libre arbitre
n'existe pas mais on ne comprend pas ce
qu'il appelle la liberté
donc il faut bien comprendre que la
seule liberté que spinoza reconnaît
c'est la liberté de dieu
ces libertés de la substance est que
cette liberté il la définit comme le
pouvoir de s'autodéterminer
c'est à dire le fait de se déterminer
soit même à être et à agir donc spinoza
à cette phrase du début de l'éthique qui
consiste à dire est dite libre
la chose qui existe par la seule
nécessité de sa nature exister par la
seule nécessité de sa nature c'est ça la
définition spinosi viennent de la
liberté vous voyez encore une fois à
quel point on est très éloignée des
conceptions classiques de la liberté 1
chez descartes par exemple la liberté
c'était le décret de l'âme un cette âme
qui était censé chez descartes pas être
soumises au déterminisme au mécanisme
des corps physique chez spinoza l'a mené
pas moins soumise au déterminisme que
les corps physique mais simplement la
liberté devient chez lui la libre
nécessité et n'oublions pas qu'en
philosophie la nécessité ça désigne
justement le fait de ne pas pouvoir être
autrement
une chose est nécessaire quand elle ne
peut pas ne pas être ce qu'elle est donc
il faut déjà commencer par accepter ce
paradoxe
cette contradiction apparente dans la
définition spinosi viennent de la
liberté pour comprendre en quoi seul
dieu peut être qualifiée d'êtres libres
est ce que veut nous dire spinoza c'est
que dieu n'a pas le choix d'être ce
qu'il est mais c'est parce qu'il est ce
qu'il est c'est parce que son être se
confond avec sa puissance c'est parce
qu'il n'ya pas de séparation entre ce
qu'il pourrait être
est ce qu'il est que dieu peut être
qualifiée d'êtres libres
si on voulait vraiment schématiser pour
ne pas dire caricaturer le propos
spinoza mme on pourrait dire que dieu
c'est celui qui ne se pose aucune
question
non pas parce qu'il se répète on pas
parce qu'ils ne seraient pas capables
d'y répondre mais tout simplement parce
qu'il sait ce qu'il est et quand on sait
ce qu'on est comme quand on sait ce
qu'on a à faire
là on le fait et chaque seconde on va
passer à réfléchir pour savoir si c'est
une bonne décision pour savoir si on a
raison si on doit le faire
du point de vue discipline aux armes ce
sont des seconds
on passe à ne pas être ce qu'on dit
c'est du temps qu'on passe à aller
contre soi c'est du temps qu'on passe à
ne pas suivre sa nature mais quand vous
savez ce que vous avez à faire
vous vous confondez avec ce que vous
faites vous vous confondez avec la
réalisation de ce que vous savez devoir
faire vous devenez ce que vous êtes et
vous est ce que vous devez faire la
liberté chez spinoza c'est la capacité à
devenir soi et à agir conformément à sa
propre nature la liberté chez spinoza
c'est la mise en oeuvre de notre
puissance au sens de notre potentiel
étant entendu que connaître son
potentiel savoir ce que l'on n'est pas
c'est peut-être ça le plus difficile est
peut-être que si nous sommes à la
recherche d'un semblant de liberté
peut-être que si nous voulons nous
extraire de la chaîne de causalité qui
régit les être physique et nous
accomplir comme ce que spinoza appelle
des êtres immortels
il est peut-être plus que temps de se
poser la question
qui sommes nous et que voulons donc
posons nous la question et devenir ce
que nous sommes
je vous remercie
[Musique]
et
coût